my immediate family is
libertarian conservative but my extended
family is not and so that has been
difficult for sure same
yeah and so it's
how do you handle it do you i usually
try to prioritize the relationships over
like minuscule political disagreements
and that's what i've tried to do
but
their response has just been to
completely walk away and shut you out
uninvite you from things that sort of
thing so it's been difficult but i don't
know what is your experience been
um i usually don't bring up certain
topics too yeah family members that i
know don't hold the same opinions i like
it it doesn't matter if it's gonna upset
that person i don't need to change their
mind like you don't need to change
everybody's mind so i usually avoid it
uh for people
who don't talk to me anymore i just
don't care like yeah at all
welcome to episode 153 of my podcast i'm
michaela peterson
in light of my dad joining daily wire
this interview features brett cooper
she's pretty impressive she's only 20
years old and she's grown her social
media following faster than anyone i've
seen
i think period but definitely in
political commentary you might recognize
her from
the comment section at daily wire that's
the show she hosts brett cooper has done
way more than the vast majority of
people her age she was homeschooled and
went to ucla when she was just 16.
she's been a successful actress for
years and she's been making waves as a
very very sharp young conservative who
says exactly what's on her mind kind of
appeals more to gen z
we spoke about private education leaving
hollywood changing people's minds
brett's background the daily wire and
more i hope you enjoy this episode this
episode was brought to you by better fed
beef i don't know if you guys keep up
with my health
lion diet i haven't done an update in a
very long time
i've moved to miami this is my new miami
room it will soon have things in the
background
i'll do an update soon but i stopped
eating beef about two years ago because
it's super aged in north america anyway
my diet has consisted of the lion diet
but mostly lamb and bison veal because
they're aged less so they don't upset my
stomach
i have
like i have such a sensitive stomach i
don't know how i've survived this long
to be honest
but then i went to croatia last year and
i could eat the beef there with zero
issues so i confirmed my belief that it
was the aging process that was actually
an issue for my stomach and that's where
better fed beef came in to save me they
made me a fresh cow
normally that's not what they do though
if you're looking for incredible beef
raised on real family farms and shipped
directly to your door
betterfedbeef.com is your place to go
better fed beef produces unique
certified anya beef through a fine-tuned
production program designed for
incredibly consistent incredibly tender
beef
a study at north dakota state university
found better fed beef to be as tender as
american wagyu at a fraction of the
price so they normally do age their beef
like normal people
so it's super tender and marbled and i
would have some to show you guys but i
ate it all
that's how good it is i would recommend
trying their beef out for sure and for
people who are super sensitive like me
they'll make unaged beef too if you
reach out and buy a large quantity
unaged isn't as tender but it works for
my stomach and for normal people
just give them a shot their beef is so
fresh and tender it's nuts blows away
the competitors i've tried and i have
tried all of them better fed beef is
made up of a network of 17 family farms
across the midwest that raise and care
for the cattle themselves they produce
cattle following certified anya
standards which control everything from
genetics and animal care to raising
practices in nutrition better fed beef
has the best tasting beef i've tried out
of a box and i've tried
everything out there they have tons of
options like the backyard barbecue box
short ribs ground beef they're low in
slow box briskets etc even if you're not
on the lion diet most people aren't
everyone can get healthier by adding
more meat to their diet and my listeners
can take a whopping 20
off their first order by going to
betterfedbeef.com
and using code mp at checkout
remember that's better fedbeef.com
real beef from real families i cannot
thank these guys enough for helping me
out i'm in love with their farming and
their beef and their company thank you
very much for helping me eat beef again
so yeah check them out guys support them
betterfedbeef.com
codemp
and i hope you enjoy this episode with
brett cooper
brett cooper welcome to my podcast
thank you happy to be here
yeah this should be fun i want to learn
a little bit about you you started
popping up all over my youtube and i was
like who is this
who is this girl so now we're gonna find
out uh before we get before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
yeah so i am the host of the comment
section at the daily wire it is a
daily uh pop culture and social media
and political commentary show
um it differs from
a lot of traditional more like
right-leaning commentary because um i'm
obviously younger i'm gen z and so a lot
of my commentary focuses on what's going
on on social media so what my generation
is interested in what is trending what
the political stories um that are you
know getting the most traction on social
media that's usually what i comment on
um and so that makes a little more
unique it makes it more fun and
relatable for me as a young person
because it's the stories that like me
and my peers are you know damning back
and forth about that we're talking about
in our group chats and it makes it more
tangible and you know relevant to my
generation so that's what i'm doing with
daily wire prior to this i attended ucla
and then did a program at uc berkeley's
high school of business
and i was an actor in los angeles for 10
years prior to that so i did the child
actor hollywood stint
then ucla then somehow ended up here
doing political commentary
okay we're going to get into all of that
i did some i did some background because
i was like there's okay you said ucla
there was something about law school it
was like how old is this chick so before
we get started how old are you yes i'm
20. okay okay so yes that that is young
to have accomplished all that most
people aren't even done university at
20. so how did you end up graduating
university before you were 20. so i
started at ucla when i was 16. i was
homeschooled for almost my entire uh
undergraduate or like primary school
career um was in a magnet school for
like two years at the kindergarten first
grade did one year at public school
hated it so because i was homeschooled i
had the ability to skip grades move
faster test out of things uh started uh
college at 16 and then finished in three
years so i graduated when i was 19 last
year
so did you go into classes in person at
ucla
i did yes i only did four so i did dual
enrollment for one year at the end of my
high school career and then i went to a
community college in los angeles and
knocked out a bunch of my
general ed credits
which i'm very glad i did there's a
stigma around community college for sure
but i think that i got a better
education in many respects at this
community college than i did at ucla
just because it was more tailored and
the professors were there for the
students rather than for the prestige
and the research um so as a result i
think that i got more hands-on exposure
there but then i transferred to ucla as
a junior and did a year and a half of
in-person classes and then covet
happened so then the rest of it was
but yes i was in classes starting
when i was 17 and then turned 18 during
my junior year
was it weird being younger did people
notice
not really people didn't notice until
they specifically like asked my age or
something would happen where it was like
oh i can't really do that because i'm
not you know i'm not 21 or i'm not
whatever um but because i had worked in
hollywood for so many years my all of my
friends were much older i had been
around adults you know i started working
professionally when i was seven i
believe so i was in an adult world at a
very young age and i think that made me
mature faster and made me more socially
adept and as a result it wasn't like oh
there's this kid in class and most
people got to know me prior to figuring
out how old i was um and so it wasn't a
huge deal especially because a lot of
the freshmen that were coming in they
were my age so it wasn't like i was yeah
you know 15. if i had started and we did
that intentionally my
i applied to some university straight
out of high school but my mom said
socially like it's going to be awful for
you if you start right now so save your
money get your general edit at a
community college where it is a more you
know non-traditional set of students and
then transfer in when you are actually
the same age as at least some of the
peers so that it makes the transition a
little bit easier and i think that was a
smart move on her part for sure
okay that's interesting so what does
your mom do how come you guys went this
non-traditional route
she is the most untraditional person
you'll ever meet so she
has had a myriad of careers she started
out as a book publisher a textbook
publisher for wwe norton she studied
under ayn rand and she's an objectivist
wow
that's cool and that's very yeah and so
she was part of ein rand's philosophical
like world in the 80s right before she
died she actually adopted iran's cat
right after she died her cat tommy was
named after thomas aquinas um and so she
was deep in that world actually
published a few objectivist textbooks um
at ww norton but ended up leaving
academia
for political and philosophical reasons
because
everything that she wanted to publish
that she felt strongly about that were
in line with her values it was like an
uphill battle and i'm sure i mean your
family knows that firsthand but
everything that she wanted to
you know work on was nope diane that's
not mainstream enough that's you know
that's too controversial we can't do
that
she left that moved to california
started her working in real estate and
since then she's just been a real estate
investor and was able to have that
passive income and be a stay-at-home mom
so then her entire career has just been
being a dynamo parent to me and my three
brothers
wow wow
so you guys all did homeschool
no we all my brothers did it for a
couple of years but they had very
non-traditional they moved around a lot
my mom's whole philosophy with parenting
was to create the most resilient and
independent uh children that she could
so as a result we moved constantly we
never you know stayed in place for
longer than maybe eight years or so
always wanted us to be you know forced
to make new friends adapt to new places
try a new school so my brothers
homeschooled for a while did public
school did a small christian school two
of my brothers went to a military school
one went to a boarding school so it was
always
um it was never her forcing us to do
those things it was you know whatever
one child was interested in if she felt
if they together felt like this is gonna
be a great experience for you you're
gonna be pushed out of your comfort zone
we'll figure out how to make that happen
for me it just ended up being that
homeschooling allowed me the flexibility
to pursue a career in something that i
was very interested in at a young age
which is
um something that i don't take for
granted because it's not a lot of people
have the opportunity to do that
but that's just for i was the baby and
so that kind of ended up working out as
my non-traditional root i guess that's
very cool that's very cool i did a
podcast on homeschooling it was an
opposing views so pro and against
homeschooling yeah
and i think it depends on who your
parents are but your mom sounded more
than capable at homeschooling that's
really interesting like um my dad tried
to pull me out he used to pull me out
for the really politically correct weeks
so it was like if somebody came into the
school or standardized testing um yeah
he'd pull us out and be like oh you get
to be homeschooled for a week we didn't
know what was going on at that point
in grade four it's like ah we're missing
a week oh that's fine whatever we don't
like school anyway uh yep so so that's
that's fun did you enjoy acting what was
being in hollywood like and what movies
have you been in
i
loved it and there is still
i don't think that there's anything that
i love more than performing i was
deathly shy when i was younger and so as
a way to get me out of my shell my mom
encouraged me to
um i did like musicals at my brother's
high school while they were in
chattanooga um which is a town outside
of nashville where i lived for a while
and while we were growing up and it was
just her way to get me on stage and to
make me comfortable being in front of
people and talking to people because i
was so uncomfortable with it and so it
just it was kind of like a utility thing
at first in a way for me to be social
and try something new ended up falling
in love with it clearly came out of my
shell
and then i just kept going around and
doing different you know theatrical
productions and that ended up being like
okay now you're moving from you know
community theater to audition to a
regional production of something okay
now you're doing like a month and a half
long run of something and you're getting
paid for it now we were driving from
chattanooga tennessee to atlanta to do a
show and i would live there for five
days of the week with my mom and do a
professional show come back to
chattanooga on the weekends i was
performing with the atlanta symphony
opera and then ended up being in new
york
auditioning for broadway shows and doing
workshops um and then i had a whole team
there i had agents and managers and it
was at around the age of 11 or so that
they said we want you to move out to los
angeles and start doing film and tv so i
ended up going out there which at that
point my mom had said she never wanted
to live in california ever again
she was born while my brothers were born
she was like damn it like this child is
like pulling me all over the country but
like i said she
is the kind of parent we had the
flexibility and she had
you know the resources and the interest
and the commitment to us you know being
developed as very distinct individuals
that whatever any of us were interested
in she found a way to make that happen
for us and so thankfully my brothers are
12 and 14 years older than me um
i was basically an only child at that
point they were off either at a boarding
school or one of them was in college at
that point that she was able to say okay
we can go to los angeles for six months
out of the year and you can work and so
i loved it hollywood in itself is
ridiculous industry it's very corrupt
it's very difficult to work in it's very
unstable and it's hard on the creatives
i don't think that's talked about a lot
but you're really whipped around by the
people who
run that world so the technical side of
it is very difficult i lucked out i had
a great team for the entire time that i
was working there so i was protected
from a lot of that by again a fantastic
parent and a really really great team
but it is difficult and that's why we
see so many you know former child actors
come out of this world just being
absolutely messed up um for very good
reason like it they chew you up and they
spit you out but the art form itself i
love it um i did more tv shows than film
so i did the reboot of heathers which is
probably my biggest thing that actually
got
canned because it was too anti-woke um
which is
it was kind of uh ironic that i got to
do something that was politically more
aligned with me i think unintentionally
but they were making fun of woke culture
when they were rebooting the classic
cult movie heathers into a tv show and
really flipped all the woke stereotypes
on its head and we were supposed to come
out around the time that the parkland
shooting happened and because there's
gun violence in heather's they scrapped
it and basically recut the entire tv
show took out a lot of the offensive
parts and then aired it and then
paramount said you're not doing another
season this was too politically
incorrect um so in a way that was sad
because that was
supposed to be this entire cast we were
all working actors but none of us had
been like never had that like skyrocket
now like oh my god you're a public
you're like a household name and it was
supposed to be that was the project that
was supposed to do that for us so it was
sad in that sense but it also kind of
feels like a badge of honor in a way
because it's like i actually got to do a
project i actually got to work on
something that was you know fighting
at least a little bit of a fight against
um some of the industry you know
political standards that hollywood has
but so how do you do that yeah that's
cool that's cool yeah okay now keep
going keep going oh no i was just gonna
say and then just some like kids tv
shows growing up i did a fox mini series
which was actually about blm ironically
so i've done you know projects on both
sides of the political spectrum lots of
indie films that sort of thing
commercials all over the place but
worked consistently for
10 years and i think a lot of people
don't they're they'll like look at my
imdb or they'll you know the people that
disagree with me politically and i'll
get like you know hate comments and that
kind of thing it's like oh my god i
can't believe daily wire hired like a
b-list like failed child actor and it's
like yeah i didn't end up being
like a household name and that was never
something that i oh come on
anybody who would say that also has
nothing going on in their lives exactly
and it's like what are you doing
i was like i don't really care but it
also is if you have that many credits
it's like from the age of you know 10 to
16 i was paying i was funding my
apartment in l.a emancipated myself at
15. and so at that point i was like
fully financially you know independent
away from my acting and it's like even
though i wasn't you know had i didn't
have millions of followers and wasn't
you know talked about at the emmys or
whatever it's like there are thousands
of actors that make a living every day
and you don't even know what their names
are um but it cracks me up that that's
their usual they haven't been able to
find many things to hate on me about and
so usually that's the one that they go
for but it just cracks me up
she graduated university too early right
yeah yeah yeah wow
that's a lot that is a lot
to do
before the last practice at the age of
20. it's a lot yeah yeah that's that's
really cool okay where does law school
come into play there
when i graduated from ucla
i had decided that i wanted to walk away
from acting for a myriad of reasons part
of which i usually talk about the
political one but
i don't think like personality type wise
i am it's not that i'm not cut out for
that industry it's just not
something that i think i'm you know that
my personality type fits in with because
as an actor as a creative you're out of
control like you are told like you have
an audition at this point uh you know at
this time of day you have to change your
entire schedule for it your shoot you
know starts at 3am and then you're
you're off at two or you might have a
night shoot that starts at 10 p.m and
you have to work around that uh within
like a three-day notice you could be you
know sent to you know vancouver to shoot
something or i would be on vacation and
they would say you have an audition
right now like you need it like this is
huge you have to film it i don't care if
you're with your family um and as a
result it makes it very difficult to
have any autonomy over you know your
life and things that you want to do
outside of acting everything really has
to be boiled out into this little bubble
that you're in and i'm interested in way
too many things so it made it very
difficult to explore that um a lot of my
team my agents and managers didn't like
that i was focusing on my education um
it was like you're going to college like
oh okay well can you still act i was
like well i can you know do auditions
outside of my class times and it was
like i
made it in my college career was
incredibly difficult in a way because i
was working around a career and that's a
choice that i made and i'm not upset
about it but i my classes were
like exclusively you know 7 30 a.m to 11
a.m so i could be available for
auditions and then i would do like
classes that would start at 6 30 and
would go to 10 p.m sometimes in the
middle of my day had to be free you know
for appointments and i just hated the
fact that i had no control over any of
it um and
as somebody that like my myers-briggs
type is like entj and i'm a
what i did an enneagram test the other
day i think i'm an eight maybe but i
might all of them you've taken my dad's
have you taken i haven't but i need you
that wasn't that you need to take that
one
i'm doing like a series where i go
through all of the tests and like your
dad's is on the list to do that next so
i'll film that and i'll make sure i send
it to you yeah
um we'll see after this maybe you can uh
you can type me but
all of my personality types are
um and what i value and i know that i
value is having control over you know my
life where i move what i do and that
industry does not allow it so all that
being said i knew that
i didn't think long term i was going to
be happy having that as a career
especially because i just value control
and stability um so i had considered
going into production and i had had you
know myriad of internships different
production companies but i had hate and
how political that side of things got
like every production company i would
work at i was working on projects that i
completely disagreed with and so as any
you know student who comes out of a
university with a liberal arts degree it
was like well law school
so did the whole application process
took the lsat got into a few california
schools and then decided i wanted to get
out of california so i applied the last
day for the university of idaho for
their dual mba jd program because my mom
had just decided to move to idaho and
got in got a scholarship decided to do
that and then the day my orientation was
supposed to start in september i
withdrew
and it was kind of it had been brewing
for a couple of weeks i talked to a few
mentors
um and i just in my gut thought i this
is kind of a cop-out like i don't really
think i want to be an attorney i think
i'm just buying myself four more years
because i feel like the world is like in
a very fl like the industry that i
wanted to be in i didn't feel
comfortable i didn't know what i wanted
to do next i was already writing for a
few political journals i had worked with
prageru a bit i already kind of had my
foot in the door with politics and it
felt like
brett you're just trying to you know
shut yourself away and do four more
years of school so you don't have to go
out and actually figure out what you
want to do and so it was a bit of a
freak out moment
and i spent a couple of months in
boise continuing to be a waitress and i
was like being a waitress at a like a
fine dining restaurant writing for the
foundation for economic education i
continued doing videos for prageru i got
a job at young americans for liberty i
was like okay i guess i'll just do this
political thing uh and then daily wire
dm'd me in october and said uh could we
bring you in to like audition for a show
we've seen your content we want to like
build something around you um and it was
kind of like i don't know whether that's
you know a god thing i don't know if
that's a you know just i always i always
wonder if it's because people have asked
me like do you think that this is some
like freak like you were blessed or you
know but i do think i
i worked for 10 years in an industry
that is you know on camera i developed
this stuff so i obviously worked for it
um but i'm just very grateful to be here
so that's kind of the law school aspect
of it i almost did it but in the end
it's it wasn't something that i was ever
you know really vying for
wow okay that's pretty fun okay let's
let's get into that yeah no it's fun i
was like i know this girl's popping up
all over my youtube and then i did some
background research and i was like wow
there's really like there's really
something here
yeah she's she's smart yeah okay so so
how is it uh working at i mean
you probably can't even tell me even if
you're over there hating it you probably
couldn't tell me but
regardless i'll assume you're telling
the truth how do you like working at uh
the daily wire do you have your freedom
that you need
i do yes i am very grateful so i
i have a lot of people that will again
people that are critical of the show or
whatever will say like this must be a
top-down
show like you're told what to say you're
just an arm of you know ben shapiro and
jeremy boring but it's not the case at
all like i have total you know veto
power over you know my show i write the
segments i put it together um i have a
very different brand than the other
hosts which is recognized and
appreciated and they know that i'm you
know i'm younger i'm a woman i am not
you know the more traditional
conservative woman and i feel very
appreciative that i'm in an environment
where that's amplified and we're going
to build something around you not try to
fit you into a mold
to make you you know more popular in
this audience it's like no we value you
because you're intelligent and you have
something to say that's of value um and
so we're gonna work around that and
amplify it so i definitely have the
freedom i definitely uh i mean this
whole team is the best of the best when
it comes to you know people in the
conservative movement like the people
who come
here to work
are
incredible and they know that they are
coming to work at a company that is
totally mission based and it's not an
easy company to work at and jeremy says
that and he is very public about it like
we
work hard and we hustle and it's day in
and day out because it's not just that
we're creating some product that's going
to make money but it's bigger than that
we are fighting this kind of uphill
battle culture war and we're the only
for-profit um
company in the conservative space that
is doing it and so
you know a lot of not i've worked in the
nonprofit sector and non-profits make
money by losing basically we was working
in fundraising for a while at young
americans for liberty and i was doing
marketing strategy for that and the way
that you make money and get donations is
like oh my god we got to platform can
you please send us money oh this awful
thing happened can you please send us
money and it works but that's how the
nonprofit sector works but
it's really empowering to be in the
for-profit sector where you really have
to
like you have to fight tooth and nail to
win and to win the consumers respect and
support and earn their dollars and as a
result it means you have much more skin
in the game and it it's like i said it's
empowering but it just goes to show like
the free market in capitalism like it's
it works and for me at least with my
personality and how i like to function
it's a great environment to be in it's
all about the hustle it's all about
creating something
number one for our culture and for this
country but also for the consumer
actually creating
a high quality product that people
actually want to you know click on buy
subscribe to
yeah well daily wire is pretty good at
being entertaining you know for a more
right-wing platform no idea it's good
compared to
and i don't want to say anything
negative about prageru but i'm not
associated with anybody so i can gregor
use well they're catchier daily wire is
catchier
like they're good that add jeremy did
for the razors
it's incredible it was great yeah yeah
he always says he's like he he
he gets to he runs this company and as a
result he gets to do like very expensive
jokes uh and he gets to do the things
that he wasn't able to do before and
it's very cool because like this company
what a lot of people don't know
is that it is run by people who started
in hollywood so it's not just a bunch of
political pundits like even ben uh was
working on being a screenwriter before
he like fully transitioned into politics
and jeremy produced films and people on
our creative team are like high level
creatives people people on my team who
actively worked in los angeles were
working on films started in hollywood so
it's not like a bunch of conservatives
that just kind of all right we'll pick
up a camera and figure it out but who
truly have that background and are
exceptionally talented and as a result
like the entertainment comes with that
and again like i love prageru but they
are at the mercy of you know their
donors and the expectations of you know
people that are giving them a lot of
money because
we are outside of that uh we in general
just have a lot more freedom with the
things that we get to produce
that's fun
that's fun
okay are you also allergic to tennessee
i'm not actually but i know that you are
that's why you're having to leave i'm in
miami now
yeah do you like it i've never been to
miami
um
yeah i do i'm a city person like i grew
up in downtown toronto so i come to
miami and i'm like yeah i feel more
comfortable plus there's the beach and
it's sunny and yeah no tennessee almost
killed me so
i feel my dad is like that um and so
he's still in tennessee and i don't know
how he's surviving but his allergies
come every year i don't know if i'm a
unicorn or if i was here at a young
enough of an age yeah i just kind of
became immune to it uh but i've never
had the issues the only come like july
and august i'll be wanting to cut my
hair off again because of how freaking
humid it is but that's the only really
bad part about it
no no it sounds good
okay let me see
what other questions do i have i have a
whole bunch of questions for you
that was a good background what's your
plan with your platform are you just
going to keep doing what you're doing
and see where it goes or do you have a
long-term strategy
i don't have a like a laid-out long-term
strategy i think because all of this
happened so fast when i moved to daily
wire my move to nashville was i mean
that all happened
i came in in october for the first time
but once i you know signed the deal it
was like within 10 days i moved here and
started and then developed comments
section
and uh released it in who end of
february i believe early march and i
don't think anybody here
had any you know idea that would blow up
how it did i mean we got a hundred
thousand subscribers in the first two
weeks we're almost at five hundred
thousand now i mean it's like and i
didn't even have a real perception of
that because i was never like a youtube
kid um one thing another unique thing
about my family and my mom is that we
were raised without television without
we barely watched any movies we were
kept yep kept off the internet didn't
have a phone until i absolutely had to
when i was like 15 but it was a flip
phone that kind of thing um i actually
didn't get like an iphone i think until
probably my
my senior year of high school so i guess
it would be
15 16 and my flip phone was when i was
like 14 or whatever
so i was kept off of the internet so as
a result i was never a youtube kid and
so i like in that first couple of weeks
i was turning into my team and i was
like this isn't normal right like this
doesn't happen and we didn't get any
paid yeah we didn't put any paid behind
it we didn't even do a big marketing
campaign it was literally daily wire was
experimenting to see like would people
respond to this girl in this type of
content that is so outside of our
traditional you know podcast style and
apparently it worked so as a result i i
have not laid out any long-term whatever
so yes we're just going to see where
this goes we're developing additional
content you know under the daily wire
brand under the comment section brand
and we'll see
where it goes hoping to get that all
started soon but it's kind of been like
oh gosh okay people are excited about
this let's figure out what we're going
to do next so
do you know what your audience
demographic is
yes so the majority of it is i think i'm
40
in the 18 to 24 year old wow okay yes
wow um and then it's pretty evenly split
uh that might be like 38 to 40 percent
and then uh the older
generations are pretty evenly split and
then on youtube it's 50 50 male and
female and on my personal social media
it's 75 male which is interesting i
thought that it was going to be a lot
more heavy just because like even hassan
[ __ ] made a whole vide the streamer
made this whole video about me and said
that i was only getting views because
like guys would watch me and i was
thinking about my social media and i was
like well on instagram it's kind of true
because most of my followers are guys
and maybe they follow me because i you
know am a
young woman or maybe they follow me for
my opinions but then when i went and i
was you know kind of responding to his
video about me i went and i looked at my
youtube you know demographics to confirm
and i was like no like it is evenly
split and so yeah it's very even and
mostly my generation which is cool
okay give me background on hassan [ __ ]
who's his baker so hassan [ __ ]
is uh probably the largest political
streamer on twitch he's fascinating he
is um
chank ugers
did i say that moment i had to say that
right i had to get my uh team to confirm
but yes he is tank euger's nephew
um and chankyuger runs the young turks
which used to be like the biggest yes
yeah so he started with them as like an
intern
um and
started producing shows for them said a
few controversial things like the united
states deserved 911 and that kind of
thing and then left the young turks and
started doing his own streaming and in
his mind his argument about me was that
i was basically copying him i'd never
even heard of him before i watched his
video but he's huge but he said she's
trying to copy me and be like a fake
streamer but he was by any means he was
not the first political streamer on
twitch but at this point he is the
largest he has a huge following um very
left-leaning uh he's probably 28 to
30-ish but has a huge i mean massive
massive influence on twitch so yes he
made a whole video
about how i was i think in his words he
said i was stealing his flow
um and so that was it it's so so
attractive when a 28 year old dude goes
after a 20 year old girl first oh yeah
that was great
that's real that's really attractive and
then saying that you know i only had any
popularity because i was a woman and i
think he called my subscribers uh
in cells he was like i'm sure your
subscriber base is only like young in
cells who care about you because you're
a girl i was like well that is you know
they're so progressive of you
that's funny okay that's lovely yeah
well you're about it i mean as soon as
you get followers you're going to get
hate online especially doing what you're
doing
yeah who who came up with the comments
section idea
it was a joint effort between a couple
of uh our creatives here at daily wire
um one of which is uh my brand manager
now but he is the he's one of my
producers but he is a youtube kid um and
he had his own youtube channel for a
long time so he is deep into you know
understanding the trends on both the
left and right um and he in all of his
you know work here with us had realized
that there's kind of this hole on the
right where we're not all of our content
on youtube especially is just like this
daily news you know sit in front of a
camera do very traditional podcast or
it's like fox news and tucker carlson
that kind of thing there isn't any kind
of streamer laid back traditional
youtube like youtuber style
um and so he wanted to create something
like that and wanted to so he started
the search to find you know uh he wanted
it to be a girl um but someone who was
already sort of engaged in politics but
had a smaller following uh to then build
a show
that was somewhere in that world so they
brought me in and they sort of had the
idea for it but we did a couple of
months of like trial episodes you know
figuring out is it purely going when i
was originally brought in
it was going to be completely apolitical
and they were like we just kind of want
you to do culture and pop culture sort
of like the tp usa politics sort of
model
um and i was
fine with that but i really pushed
for the political content and they were
worried that it was going to be you know
it was when i if i would do political
content it would become too traditional
and the things we wanted to avoid and i
was like i promise like let's just like
massage it let's do a bunch of episodes
i promise that i can present it in a way
use this structure that we've come up
with but do it in a way that will be
palatable to young people and we'll hit
that market that we're trying to do so
it took a little bit of like time of
figuring out like well what stories am i
going to focus on okay let's just focus
on like the social media ones this
that's the stuff that interests me um
and then i'm able to joke about it i'm
able to you know read the comments
figure out what people are actually
saying not just hear what like pundits
and what you know the mainstream media
is responding to these stories about but
literally if you go into the comment
section on any videos you can kind of
figure out
what the general public is thinking and
feeling and it's highly entertaining so
that all sort of came together so
started with one person and then molded
once i got in and you know really
changed and then popped out on youtube
in march
wow okay so i must have come across you
in march or april like right at the
beginning
yeah
huh impressive okay how do you choose
stories to comment on
yeah
on top of that
yes yeah it's a daily once i so i film
comment section in the morning
i come in
around 7 30 8 a.m usually and i will
um
go over what i've picked out because i
usually pick it up the night before and
just in case anything has dramatically
changed if there's a story that's you
know coming overnight i want to make
sure that i have ample time to change
direction if i need to usually go get
ready and then we start filming around
nine or ten then it's all edited in one
day and it's released that evening so
once i'm finished filming a bunch of
other projects i work on with daily wire
i write a lot of articles for our um
website so i'll be doing that sort of
thing but throughout the day i'm
constantly monitoring it's usually
twitter tick tock uh and reddit
and twitter is where i get a lot of my
biggest stories because you can easily
go on their trending page same with
reddit and see what like are the hot
stories that kind of thing um and i
start there i never even though i know
that things are going on in the world i
will never pick a story just because
like fox news is talking about it cnn is
talking about it i intentionally wait
until it makes its way to social media
because there's some stuff that is
interesting to me that's like okay
that's a big story but nobody cares
about it on reddit nobody's making tick
tocks about it my generation that is
online truly for some reason doesn't
care about this issue and so
that is like okay that's a signal to me
that's probably not the story that i
want to cover so i wait until
you know i see that it has you know 75
000 likes that this got ratioed that the
comments are you know going crazy people
are making memes about it that kind of
thing
and that kind of directs
like this is where i want to put my
energy um and it's
yeah it's been pretty foolproof uh and
obviously social media moves so quickly
so that makes it easier because i'm not
just sitting around waiting for
something to pop up there's always
something but it's kind of you know
determining
what uh is the most the other layer on
that is that i also never want it just
to be like a fluff story because i could
sit here all day and just talk about the
kardashians or talk about something
taylor swift did or there's this funny
video that's going around that has no
context the other layer something that i
look for is can i relate this to
either a broader political conversation
a broader cultural conversation a lot of
stuff that i've been talking about
recently
um
goes back to like the mental health
crisis that we have in this country in
the world right now especially with gen
z um if i can relate any of those
stories even if they are pop culture if
i can bring it back to okay this is a
message that i
think that my audience and that you know
society as a whole that would be
beneficial for them to hear talked about
that we can relate it to something
that's more important that way i'm not
just sitting around being like oh my god
can you believe the kardashians were
that
i'm going to talk about them i usually
talk about their terrible political
takes or you know how out of touch um
the elites are or that sort of thing or
you know based on the men that they're
dating why are we going towards very
like feminine men or you know this like
very
uh you know different cultural trend so
as a result it makes it more interesting
to me because i you know i'm using my
brain i'm being more intellectual with
like the content that i'm picking so all
of that sort of goes into it
wow okay
that's quite a bit i like the
kardashians i like them i've never seen
i've never seen their show and i had
that is true but in order to make that
much money those people have to be smart
particularly the mom who's the mom no
yeah she's a snake it's fantastic like
everybody really knows she really
worries what she's doing yes she's
coordinated years in advance she's yes
she's smart everything is laid out
everything you have a contract for
everything yeah um and i do have a
problem when people say oh they are only
like they're only famous because they
put their asses out on instagram
whatever and it's like yes that is true
they are influencers but those women do
run like billion dollar business
so and like kim is going to law school
she's or whatever she's doing trying to
be a lawyer
and it's like you have to have some
level of competence and intelligence to
manage all of that so i give you credits
for that even though sometimes i think
that their takes are weird and they can
be out of touch it's like okay i'll give
you well out of touch that's for sure
did you see yeah did you see her recent
ad for beyond meat where she oh my god
yes didn't actually eat the burger and
it was chewy it was so funny that was so
funny
it was great i love the uh the chief
taste consultant brand that she's
putting on herself and people were just
laughing about it and then when you do
your research and you see that beyond
meets like stocks are tanking i think
that it's gone down 80 in the last 11
months or something like that it's like
this is their desperate attempt to save
their company is kim kardashian faking
loving their fake meat fake eating
i wonder how much meat i know i wonder
how much that tanked their stocks that
must have cost a lot too to get some
kardashians that must have cost a lot
yeah okay i'm glad we covered
homeschooling i think homeschooling is
important right now uh given how scary
the schooling system is i got scarlett
into a school in miami that seems pretty
good it doesn't seem ideologically
possessed and i've been thinking too i
was like well what do you do with a kid
so she's four she's about to go into
kindergarten the school looks good
they've got a pontoon boat as if that's
necessary for somebody in kindergarten
and like tortoises and things yeah right
just they teach programming and robotics
and i was like that sounds that's that
sounds that sounds pretty good but the
entire thing so you can tell me your
opinion on this i think the entire thing
is kind of a farce so i went to
university and i did i did half of my
degree degree in psychology and classics
and then
uh i dropped out because i was extremely
ill and i went to make up school of all
things for about six months and my dad
was like what are you doing you're not
going to get enough intellectual
stimulation and makeup school yeah i was
like what do you know dad and he was
right but uh so i went back to school
and i went into biomedical sciences for
a couple years
uh and then
i got pregnant and had scarlet so i
dropped out for that and at the same
time dad kind of shot to fame and i
started managing
his affairs i guess you could say and
growing his social media presence online
and i was like what's the purpose of
going back to university
like this is a full-time job what am i
gonna go take more science yeah courses
like for what purpose if the purpose of
school is to get a job
right so you already have one yeah
yeah so you said you went to community
you got your general education degree i
don't know how this works at all and you
you could do that early so can you just
get that at any point
yes so
there's even another layer of weirdness
in california there's the thing there's
a thing called the chesapeake which is
basically california's equivalent of
their ged certificate in high school so
i took it's called the california high
school proficiency examination and you
can take that um once you've hit a
certain level in math or when you are
like a second semester sophomore in high
school
i
hit those requirements when i was 13. so
i went in and you do like a state
sanctioned test and you basically get
your chest b certificate and once you
have hit those requirements it basically
says you have gotten that which is kind
of sad and not that a 13 year old could
have done that but that the the baseline
is so low but they say
once you have passed that test you have
gotten like the baseline you know
knowledge that you need from high school
and you are then with the chesapeake
it's a good system when you have this
chesapeake certificate you are then
allowed to work as a high school
graduate as an 18 year old and it was
designed for
people who um you know kids needed to
work to be able to support their
families or and it helped with like
child actors especially because then a
lot of the labor laws change when you uh
turn 18 and you're a high school
graduate then you don't need a tutor on
set it's less expensive to hire you
because you don't have to do like set
school hours i could just kind of i
would be on set and be in my trailer and
do my school myself i wouldn't have to
have a
you know production teacher being there
to monitor everything
so there's a lot of things that go into
it but the other uh
thing that you get when you take the
chesapeake is that you are then able to
take community college classes outside
of a coordinated uh
there's a lot of programs united states
where high schools will set up
agreements with community colleges or
just universities in general where you
can take a couple of classes as a high
schooler it's outside of the ap advanced
placement curriculum
and so that allowed me having that
certificate allowed me to go just take
community college classes so i stayed in
my online high school that i was doing i
was not by the by the time i got into
high school my mom stopped building my
curriculum and i was in an online
private school so she
built or she stopped teaching me she
didn't stop building the curriculum so
she would create the curriculum she
would work with the teachers at the
private high school
and uh she you know looked at all the
book lists i remember at one point like
when my 10th grade year they were only
gonna have me they were only going to
have me read uh like five books for the
entire semester and she was like my
daughter reads to like one to two books
a week like this is not enough she's
going to be sitting around doing nothing
so we bumped that up to like i was
reading 30 books in a semester yeah and
none of them were my it was like all
classics she was like i don't want to
reading anything you know written after
the year 2000 like we need to focus on
all this um history classes she because
she worked in publishing she knew what
textbooks she wanted me to read for like
u.s history she was like this one was
written at like this time i love the
author this is great so she was very
involved but she was not the one grading
my paper she didn't have to like hold my
hand while i was sobbing doing calculus
even though she hatched the tears when i
had to do that or chemistry that kind of
thing because she knew that those were
not my strengths and did not want to be
a part of that but anyway so i was doing
by the time that i took the just be
i was able to go start doing community
college classes in addition to the
online program that i was doing um so
started knocking out those credits but i
and i got an associate's degree through
the community college um and i don't
this whole culture especially the united
states i don't know how it is in canada
um that tells young people that their
entire like middle to high school career
is all about getting into the university
canada and it's like you have yeah and
it's like everything all of your
extracurriculars it's not about what are
you interested in it's what is going to
look good on your application when
you're volunteering and you're doing you
know charity that sort of thing it's
ever about what am i actually interested
i want to do good work it's like i need
to show that i did like 50 hours at a
freaking animal shelter to prove that
i'm a good person so that harvard will
let me in it's all so manufactured and
it strips young people from being able
to actually be innovative and be
creative and find their passions and
actually work that's why gen z is the
least experienced generation going into
the workforce because we were all so
damn focused on getting into ivy leagues
rather than
flipping burgers at mcdonald's working i
worked at trader joe's for five years
throughout high school and college
because acting is very inconsistent i
never wanted to take social security
like a lot of my friends in hollywood
did and because
my mom
all of my brothers you know worked
traditional like after school jobs my
mom worked her way through high school
and college she was like just because
you're making money and you're in this
like fancy career doesn't mean that you
get to skip out on having real world
punching a clock having that experience
um but a lot of i i honestly look at
that as like a privilege that i got to
do that um and somehow you know still
got into college even though i wasn't
you know on every sports team you know
volunteering at the animal shelter that
kind of thing but this whole push to say
that you know your entire life is
culminating to your 18th birthday when
you have to like you know apply for
these colleges get in and then you have
four years and then you figure out how
to get a job um because like you're
saying
if you're already working if you already
know what you're interested in yeah why
waste all of that time especially if
it's something that you could just go do
now if you could go to a community
college knock out a few of those credits
and then go get a job if you could go to
trade school um and like especially the
push for the private like liberal arts
schools like i
i had a member of my family tell me when
i was applying to the ucs so uc berkeley
and ucla primarily he said are you going
to apply to any real colleges i said
yeah and all of his kids were like ivy
league bound he and his wife
my uncle went to um you know harvard and
columbia william and mary
um and they're like are you going to
apply to any real colleges like those
are state schools it's like ucla is the
best public university in the country do
you think because it is like state-run
because it's not a private liberal arts
school that it's not good enough but i
mean there's this entire
culture that is like
royally fw gen z in a way i mean the
last two generations honestly where i
think we've been stripped of our ability
to
you know really mature as workers and
you know mature our interests and our
like adult skills uh because we're so
focused on just trying to get into a
stupid you know gender studies program
basically
yeah that's pretty miserable everybody
should have to be burnt by greece at
some point during yeah exactly and
during i guess teenage years yeah as a
job but here you go
exactly but no so i totally agree with
you and if you're already working
i mean i would see
you know friends who one of the
conundrums for me was
i grew up working as a professional
actor everybody in my like friend group
and community we were all professionally
working
and when they would turn 18 they'd be
like okay well i have to go to college
and i'm going to go for theater and
acting and i would look at them and i
feel like you've been working
professionally making money doing this
why would you go spend 80 grand a year
being taught how to do something that
you are already doing
like you can go take an acting class
outside of college like if you do want
to go if that's important to you is
important to me go for something
academically that's interesting or learn
a tangible skill go to a trade school
while you're doing it like don't just go
and do theater classes when you've been
it was just mind-boggling to me and i
truly didn't understand it but it was so
ingrained in their brain that it was
like well no i want to be an actor after
i graduate so i must do the acting
program and i utterly rejected that i
was like no that's ridiculous like i
want to go read literature and i want to
learn about business and biological
anthropology and like all of that um so
it's just a whole the whole culture
around it is weird
yeah it is weird i think it was hard for
somebody well you know my dad he's a
university professor
so it was pretty hard on him for me not
getting a degree right even though i was
running his business i was like dad like
i don't have time it's like we finished
school at the same time i can't like you
don't understand the background work
that goes into like building things like
i can't do it um like we could get
somebody else to do it you want to get
somebody else to do it and i'll finish
my degree and it's like
well that doesn't really make sense and
i was like yeah it doesn't really make
sense like what's the purpose what's the
purpose of the degree right and if
you're educating yourself too i mean you
can get an education online you don't
have to go anywhere like everything is
available online for free yep yes yeah
i think it's just that jobs require it
right they're like what's your degree
yeah
right and that's one
fantastic thing about daily wires that
we don't ask for because a lot our execs
a lot of them didn't graduate from
college and so we have this culture
where it's like we don't ask you don't
have to be a college graduate and it's
it's fan we get so again we get so many
talented people because we are looking
outside of the traditional the
conventional you know job market and i
think a lot of companies shoot
themselves in the foot because they do
you must have this you know bs degree
and whatever it's like yes they might
have you know learned some critical
thinking they learned how to be a good
writer i totally believe in those skills
but you also don't have to spend that
much money at a university you know have
to sit through the intersectionality
classes deal with all of the you know
political in the sense of policy but
also like the bureaucracy of a
university you don't need that and if
you are an academic if you are
interested in that um then by all means
go for it i loved it but not a lot of
people are built like that um and it's
just
completely backwards to think that
everybody can fit into that you know
perception that mold
yeah for sure i think that's how elon
musk hires people too you should hire a
baseball competence
right yes
yeah yeah
for sure okay right what's your favorite
book
uh um
god
probably it's very cliche
but
i don't actually don't know if it is but
jane eyre
has jane eyre is a great book yes jane
eyre is a great book yeah it's one of
those words oh go ahead have you read
wuthering heights
i have i didn't like it as much
i appreciated it
but there's something about jane as a
character
um that has always stuck with me and the
it's it's an incredibly complex novel i
think a lot of people just like focus on
jane's you know relationship with
rochester like rochester and that sort
of thing but the whole mad woman in the
attic narrative uh with rochester's wife
that is still living up there is a
there's so many different lanes that you
can go down when you're studying it and
understanding it where it's like there's
also the that was at the time when women
who were
more outspoken
vocal opinionated were
what was it called hysteria where you
had like an upside-down uterus um and
you were called you were literally
mentally insane you were deemed mentally
insane it's like that short stories
written in america the yellow wallpaper
i think it's by charlotte perkins
gilmore i believe but it's about a woman
who was diagnosed with hysteria locked
in a room and then is made to go more
insane because she's not allowed to
leave these four walls yeah and start
seeing the wallpaper
and so there's this whole conversation
of was his wife actually batshit crazy
or did they make her that way because
they diagnosed her with this mental
illness and then there's on the other
side because they talk about the color
of her skin a lot that there's kind of
the race angle that goes in with like
did they deem that she was insane
because she was like a native they talk
about her being like a savage and that
kind of thing so that is probably my
favorite part of the entire book because
it's all of these like socio
cultural undertones that are underneath
this like romance and this like
beautifully set gothic
novel uh that really makes it come alive
so i love that uh semi more modern
because of course my mom said it under
iron rand um i love we the living which
is i don't know if it's one of i don't
think it's her most obviously it's not
her most popular because everybody
usually goes with
um atlas shrugged and the fountainhead
but it's her more autobiographical work
and her hair
oh you would love it it is absolutely
fantastic and it is i mean she writes
female characters
better than anybody in my opinion and
it's very cool because even people who
like passionately disagree with
everything that she stands for can still
read especially the fountainhead and me
the living and to appreciate the fact
that she's a brilliant novelist and that
her characters are you know
absolutely dynamic and she really walks
that line of
her philosophy and objectivism
comes through everything that she writes
but she does it in such a way that you
don't feel like you're being like
punched in the face with it um it really
is embedded in all the characters so i
love that the alchemist is a fantastic
book and probably the
um
more modern
uh most modern would probably be um a
secret history by donna tartt he's
probably my favorite
more modern in the last you know few
years
i like it
okay uh
do you have advice for other 20 year
olds
um
be okay with being unconventional
and i think strive to be unconventional
and think outside of the box and i don't
mean like oh just be like quirky and be
yourself because i think that's like a
very overused and cliche thing but it is
okay to go against the grain again it's
like if you don't want to go to college
if you want to focus on you know
building a career um if you want to have
a non-traditional like education
even if like even with your family i
don't have and it's interesting being in
the conservative world i don't have like
a very traditional healthy nuclear
family uh which is something that people
talk about a lot and i kind of sit there
and i'm like yeah well somehow i made it
out without that very traditional but
it's like i am very much i don't believe
that blood is you know thicker than
water in a lot of ways i do think that
you choose your own family um i think
you have to take accountability for the
people in your life and what is serving
you and you have to figure out where to
set those boundaries and if that means
walking away from something that is
traditional that society is telling you
oh you need to focus on this it's okay
to take account for
um you know what is making you a better
person what is making you productive and
if you know things in your life are
holding you back figure out how to
readjust and move away from that and
find something that's healthier um
i also think this is my again my
objectivist upbringing talking but i do
think that like productivity is the most
important
you know thing in our life because we
are constantly striving to make the
world a better place to contribute
something tangible whether it's
you know thoughts communications or
you're building something um
find like i don't know the enjoyment in
building and contributing something to
society because if you do that you will
have an incredibly fulfilling career and
you will be able to make money if you're
just sitting around you know asking
other people for handouts what can they
do for me that kind of thing you need to
start figuring out what you can build
what you can offer other people
um i think for me at least that's been
my path to success
i love it that was an excellent answer
uh what what's the most uncomfortable
thing that's happened to you since you
kind of
got a following
something online
um
has anything been particularly upsetting
not really and i think that's because
i'm very i'm grateful for that because
obviously it is out there and i
you know get the threats i get hate you
know there's people i never really
talked about this a lot because they
usually talk about the positive stuff
but i mean people dm you and say like i
hope you get raped like i hope you die
like that sort of lovely
and yes exactly and it's like okay
wonderful you are like a 45 year old
like fat old man sitting behind a screen
or you're some like 12 year old that
thinks you are like edgy by saying this
and a lot of that stuff i'm kind of like
okay that's normal every person that's
you know right of center that has an
ounce of common sense and breaks from
the narrative you're going to get that
it doesn't matter what industry you're
in if you break from mainstream
narrative in our culture right now it's
so polarized people are going to lose
their damn mind
but it rolls off of me
very easily i think because i was in a
career
where i was judged constantly for my
entire youth
okay acting you get told no 99 of the
time you audition six times a week and
it's like you are too thin you're too
fat you're not blonde you don't look
enough like uh the person who's playing
your father oh you're too tall because
you're a head taller than the boy who'd
be playing your love interest oh we
didn't like how you did this um
you're crying wasn't you know authentic
enough whatever it's like every day you
are shot down and a lot of the times you
are judged purely on things that you
can't control
um and as a result i got very good at
handling rejection i got very good at
people not liking me for whatever reason
and even though it's a very different
career and they're not liking me for
different reasons that became something
that i was comfortable with and i
actually did a post about this recently
when i started
branching out politically not branching
out but
talking about it openly on my social
media and you know coming out to my
friends which kind of you have to do
weirdly when you are in a very like
leftist world i guess being in hollywood
being at a university um
i kind of had to re-learn that and apply
what had served me as an actor and like
let me you know have success in that
industry without being like depressed
and anxious all the time because
everybody was judging me and apply that
to a new career where it's really like i
i understand that not everybody will
like me i literally i cannot please no
matter how hard i try i cannot please
everyone on the internet everyone in the
world and understanding that is
incredibly freeing because it's like
great then you know screw it i don't
really care
um and i'm going to do my best to be a
kind person and be empathetic but also
not shut up about the things that i
think are important and my opinions
because there are people out there who
agree and there are you know minds that
i can change people that i can connect
with and if you don't like it that's
fine
and so as a result i think it's been
easier for me so the stuff
that has been hate or whatever has not
made the biggest impact what has been
has the stuff that's offline and it's
literally like the responses of family
and friends just because i was
i was in such a leftist world
where my opinions that i have that i'm
not talking about are like you are the
devil if you speak about these so
lost a lot of friends i have people that
will call me like drunkenly at 11 and
like 11 at night and say like why are
you being mean to people online like you
need to stop and it's like damn okay i
think i need to like change my phone
number at this point
um because i have all these people from
like a past life basically that despise
the fact that i'm speaking out against
like things that they believe in um you
know i have a very
my immediate family is
libertarian conservative but my extended
family is not and so that has been
difficult for sure same
yeah and so it's
how do you handle it do you i usually
try to prioritize the relationships over
like minuscule political disagreements
and that's what i've tried to do
but
their response has just been to
completely walk away and shut you out
uninvite you from things that sort of
thing so it's been difficult but i don't
know what has your experience been
um i usually don't bring up certain
topics too yeah family members that i
know don't hold the same opinions like
it doesn't matter if it's going to upset
that person i don't need to change their
mind like you don't need to change
everybody's mind so i usually avoid it
for people
who don't talk to me anymore i just
don't care
like yeah at all i don't care i don't
have enough energy to take care of even
a little bit i think maybe initially i
cared but now it's like
really
really you're gonna walk away okay i
have tons of other things to do
so
so probably by
trying to be compassionate to people who
don't agree and avoid the topics that
make people uncomfortable if it's family
or just like okay we're not going to be
friends we don't have to be friends with
everybody
yeah if they still
want to be in my life in some capacity
because i have had a lot of you know
friends and family members just be like
okay well now i'm just not going to talk
to you with that it's the same like you
said um i think energy is a very good
word it's like i can only give so much
of myself to people and if you are not
even willing to take a step in my
direction to meet me halfway because
we're blood because i've known you since
birth since you were there when i was
born then why would i
try
and for the people that are willing to
take that step and you know stay in
contact in some regard still have an
ounce of kindness then it's like okay i
won't bring it up and it is difficult
when you are a public figure in a way
because obviously there's no hiding it
like they know what you believe they
know what your dad says you know the
same with me like they want they can see
my videos and other things that i say um
and if they are willing to like overlook
that and still be here then it's like
okay i don't need to fight with you i
don't need to bring it up if you say
something absolutely ridiculous then
like i'll be fine just sitting because
at least you're here um and i think a
lot of people get into meaningless
fights it's like okay well i still value
this relationship so
yeah and some people can't change their
mind that easily like there are more
open individuals and you can have a
conversation with them and no one's that
neurotic and then you can end up in a
place where you're like oh yeah maybe i
said something wrong or did something
wrong or believed something different
and then you grow and then there are
some people for some reason probably
lack of openness that just say no i
don't want to hear it i can't handle it
makes me emotional i don't want to go
there and there's no point in engaging
with those people unless you're trying
to hurt their feelings really right
so it's tricky which progress is nothing
yeah yeah there's no point right a waste
of time
yeah
oh well that's good so can you tell me
what an average day for you looks like
yeah so i like i said come into work 7
30 to 8 a.m every day
um and i
go into hair and makeup at 8 30. that's
one of things with daily wire that we're
very fortunate to have is because
everything is like a very high quality
production value
um do have which is great because i
don't know how to do my own makeup and
i'm terrible at it did not go to makeup
school for six months so i we have a
team that does that and then i came in
handy
there we go look at that now you're on
camera exactly so it's worth it
um i go into hair and makeup we start
filming around 9 30 and i'm usually out
of my shoot depending on how long my
segments are how many extra things i'm
having to do around 10 30 to 11.
my editors who are fantastic get started
on
clipping the show together and usually
um i run through it pretty quickly there
isn't a lot of like oh i want to say
this you know i because it's not really
scripted i know the points that i want
to make but it's very off the cuff so
the only like retakes that i'll do are i
i mispronounce a lot of words and so if
i say something sort of incorrectly it's
like okay i know that word was not said
correctly
so it's them kind of cutting through
that and changing camera angles
and after i'm finished
i start pulling things for the next
day's show i write articles we work on
development for other projects i do
promotion for the other daily wire you
know movies and films that we're doing
i'll do collaborations with our other
hosts like the other day i was doing you
know you know a shoot with ben for like
a social media thing
matt walsh came on my show and i went
and did a book signing with him and i'll
go like hop onto michael's show so it's
a very it's like i'm bouncing around
yep doing different social media hits um
we do kind of news videos that go on our
daily wire social media so i'm usually
in that where it's like okay brett
there's this story just happened let's
pull some bullet points together and do
like a three-minute video on this so
i'll go shoot that so it's a lot of
running around
doing different you know film projects
while also writing an article pulling
stuff
and then by the end of the day i usually
have the outline of what i want to talk
about uh in the morning and we get out
at different times every day it's kind
of they often say i mean it's a news
organization so our office is open you
know 24 7. uh 365 days a year because
there's always something going on so if
you know what is a woman is premiering
then we're here until you know however
long it needs to be if there's a film
coming out uh we stick around so it's
very i think that's why i like working
here so much is because and my job is
because my days are never the same it's
always a different story that i'm
covering it's always different projects
there's no
okay i'm gonna go in and i'm gonna do
the same thing and talk to the same
people i'm gonna hit the same buttons
um that i feel very grateful because i
know a lot of people aren't in that
situation but for me and somebody who's
interested in a lot of stuff and i get
very bored easily uh which is why i've
moved jobs so much moved places that
kind of thing and so it keeps me
entertained
yeah i feel that okay that's great oh
well i'm happy for you that's really fun
it's fun growing these things yeah
yeah
can you pour your you know your heart
and soul into it and so it's and it's
nice to not just be
the face of it but to really have like
my hands are in all of the development
and where i want to take the show and
that sort of thing so every day it's
like a challenge okay this video didn't
get as many views why is that let's
figure it out let's problem solve i want
to do this okay i want to create this
with daily wire who do i need to talk to
in order to get this ball rolling so
it's always like
if you want
it's the same thing with acting where
it's like if you want success in this
industry in this company you have to be
absolutely hungry and you have to be
innovative and you have to be willing to
try new things and take risks
so it's exciting
uh exhausting and sort of scary at times
because you never know what people are
going to say but keeps it interesting
good good okay well if people aren't
following you where can they go online
to follow you uh on my social media
platforms you can find me at i'm brett
cooper on twitter and instagram i also
have a tick tock that is uh the comment
section with bc and then on youtube it
is the comment section with brett cooper
and that is my daily show
okay i would recommend checking it out
it's very entertaining i'm not used to
that content i think i missed it i'm 30
and i'm just not i kind of watch it i'm
like
i get it i get it but i think it's more
of a gen z thing
which i guess corresponds with your
audience yeah it's catchier it's
catchier than a podcast
i should be doing that
attention spans because with the world
that we grew up in with you know how
fast you know our videos go it's like
gen z has like a three minute like you
have to be hooked
uh or else like you're losing most of
them um but it was sort of the same
thing when we were pitching the show we
were like fully getting it approved and
greenlit i remember sitting in a meeting
and jeremy has said this publicly too
he was on a couple of podcasts where he
told the story but we were sitting in
the meeting and he looked at me and he
was like i don't get it but he was like
but i know that's good and i know people
will get it but he was like this show is
not for me and i don't understand it
but it's going to reach somebody and
clearly it has um so he's able to he's
incredibly creative and he's able to see
what is going to work and what won't
even if it doesn't fit like his purview
his generation and i think that's
another fantastic thing about you know
the leadership here is that they are
willing to step outside of the
traditional you know conservative model
the traditional whatever because they
know that you know different kind of
content will reach different
generations types of people genders that
kind of thing yeah that's really good oh
that's good that that indicates success
too
i couldn't get into tick tock either
i don't know i don't know what it was
like instagram i get
youtube i get like long-form content i
get and tick-tock it's like no
no i can't do it i don't know what it is
i don't know what it is but yeah their
algorithm is different the type of
content is different and the audience
has very different wants too it's a
whole different ballgame it's not
they're not synonymous at all so you're
not alone in that because it's a very
it's wildly different
interesting
okay brett uh i'm gonna let you go thank
you very much for coming on it was nice
meeting you you're definitely yes you're
gonna go places you've already been
places so i'm excited to see what
happens
i appreciate it well thank you so much
this was tons of fun i'm glad we were
able to do it